♪ ♪
>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR THE
FRIEND ZONE.
WE BRING ON ONE OF OUR FRIENDS
FROM HERE AT BOX ONTO THE SHOW.
TONIGHT, OUR OLD FRIEND
BRET BAIER.
HE HOSTS "SPECIAL REPORT."
HE'S NOT JUST A NEWS MAN AND A
POLITICAL EXPERT, HE'S ALSO A
HISTORY BUFF.
A BEST-SELLING AUTHOR.
A NEW BOOK OUT TOMORROW.
"THREE DAYS IN MOSCOW."
BRET BAIER JOINS US TONIGHT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: DOUG BRINKLEY, ONE
OF THE MOST FAMOUS, MAY BE THE
MOST FAMOUS REAGAN HISTORIAN
CALLS THIS ONE OF THE BEST AND
MOST ESSENTIAL BOOKS EVER
WRITTEN ABOUT RONALD REAGAN.
I'M IMPRESSED.
>> AND I DIDN'T EVEN PAY HIM.
>> Tucker: IT'S AMAZING.
THREE DAYS.
SORT OF BOILED DOWN THE PIVOTAL
MOMENT TO THREE DAYS.
WHAT THREE DAYS?
>> IS THE THREE DAYS OF THE
FOURTH SUMMIT BETWEEN REAGAN AND
GORBACHEV WHERE REAGAN GOES TO
MOSCOW AND HE MEETS WITH
GORBACHEV.
THEY ARE FINALIZING THE NUCLEAR
ARMS TREATY, BUT HE ALSO GIVES
AN UNCOVERED AND OVERLOOKED FOR
THE MOST PART SPEECH TO MOSCOW
STATE UNIVERSITY STUDENTS AND
TAKES Q&A FROM THEM.
WE USE THREE DAYS TO JUMP BACK
AND LOOK AT HOW REAGAN GETS TO
THIS POINT AND REALLY LEADS TO
THE SEMINAL MOMENT OF THE
COLD WAR COMING TO AN END, THE
WALL COMING DOWN AND COMMUNISM
REALLY TAKING A HIT.
THE WHOLE WORLD WAS CHANGED SOON
AFTER THAT.
>> Tucker: WHAT DID REAGAN
KNOW ABOUT COMMUNISM OR THE
SOVIET UNION THAT OTHERS MISSED?
>> FROM THE VERY BEGINNING HE
THOUGHT THAT COMMUNISM WAS JUST
NOT GOING TO MAKE IT AND THAT IT
WAS DESTINED, AS HE SAID IN HIS
SPEECH, HE SPOKE ABOUT THAT FOR
A LONG TIME EVEN BACK WHEN HE
WAS PRESIDENT OF THE
SCREEN ACTORS GUILD FIGHTING
COMMUNISM IN HOLLYWOOD AND YOU
SEE THAT THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE.
GIVES SOME REALLY STINGING
SPEECHES INCLUDING CALLING THE
SOVIET UNION AND EVIL EMPIRE.
BUT WHEN GORBACHEV COMES UP, HE
SEES AND GORBACHEV SOMEONE HE
CAN NEGOTIATE WITH.
HE WAS TOUGH AND SOME OF THOSE
SUMMITS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF BEHIND THE
SCENES, NEW NUGGETS, INTERVIEWS,
I INTERVIEWED SECRETARY OF STATE
GEORGE SCHULTZ, WHO IS A
NATIONAL TREASURE.
AT HIS AGE, REMEMBERS MEETINGS
LIKE THEY WERE YESTERDAY.
SOME ORAL HISTORIES THAT REALLY
HAD NEVER BEEN DUG INTO ABOUT
BEHIND THE SCENES AND IT REALLY
PAINTS A PICTURE OF HOW THE
COLD WAR COMES TO THE END.
>> Tucker: INTERESTING.
I HAVE AN OFFICE NEXT TO YOURS
SO I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS BOOK FOR A WHILE.
WHAT DID YOU COME AWAY THINKING
ABOUT REAGAN?
DID IT CHANGE YOUR VIEW OF HIM?
>> I THINK AT THE TIME HE WAS
UNDERAPPRECIATED.
THERE WERE A LOT OF BOOKS
LOOKING BACK FAVORABLY TO
REAGAN, BUT THIS IS MORE
REPORTING ON HISTORY AND SOME OF
THE BEHIND THE SCENES MOMENTS
AND SPEECHES.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN HE GIVES THAT
SPEECH IN BERLIN AT THE GATE,
TEAR DOWN THIS WALL,
MR. GORBACHEV, THERE WERE ABOUT
TEN PEOPLE INSIDE THE
WHITE HOUSE WHO DID NOT WANT HIM
TO SAY THAT.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT TOOK IT OUT
OF THE SPEECH MULTIPLE TIMES.
HE KEPT ON PUTTING IT BACK IN.
AND HE WENT TO THAT SPEECH WITH
IT NOT IN AND WE HAD A
CONVERSATION IN THE LIMO ON THE
WAY TO THE WALL WHERE HE TURNS
TO AN AIDE AND SAYS THE GUYS AT
STATE ARE GOING TO KILL ME, BUT
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO
AND HE PUTS IT BACK IN.
THAT SPEECH HAPPENS ON JUNE 12TH
1987.
WE HAVE A BIG SUMMIT COMING UP
JUNE 12TH IN SINGAPORE AND I
DIDN'T PLAN IT THAT WAY, BUT
THERE IS SOME SYNERGY THEIR OWN
HISTORY.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU IMAGINE
BEING THE GUY WHO TOOK OUT THE
PHRASE TEAR DOWN THIS WALL?
[LAUGHS]
I HOPE HISTORY TREATS HIM BADLY.
THIS BOOK IS OUT TOMORROW.
THESE ARE NOT JUST THE NORMAL
BLURBS YOU GET FOR YOUR FRIENDS,
GREAT BOOK, BUY TWO COPIES.
THESE ARE UNBELIEVABLE AND THEY